[Applause]
[Music]
the cold war ended a long time ago or at
least that's what they want us to
believe because in old europe there is a
region where the shadow of moscow is
still very present so much so that you
could almost say that in a way the cold
war is still alive three decades after
the extinction of the soviet union and
this is precisely the region that will
be the focus of our attention today far
to the north and wedged between central
europe and scandinavia on the friendly
side and russia and belarus on the
hostile side are the three baltic states
estonia latvia and lithuania
[Music]
the three baltic states were part of the
soviet union itself until its collapse
in 1991. that is to say estonia latvia
and lithuania were not satellite states
like poland or hungary but part of the
great communist power itself however
above all the question that concerns us
is that the baltics were and still are a
key issue for moscow with their
privileged access to the baltic sea a
sea that connects them directly with the
engine of europe germany what's more the
three republics have become one of the
most prosperous regions in europe
the fact is that for these and other
reasons many military experts consider
this region to be a potential powder keg
a center of deep political and military
tensions above all military ones
lithuania says two russian military jets
violated its airspace
natojet spot russian military aircraft
near latvian border
estonia said russian planes violate its
airspace again as you can see the baltic
states a relatively small strip of 175
000 square kilometers equivalents to the
size of a country like uruguay have
become quite the headache for nato
[Music]
in order to counteract the russian
threats protecting the borders and
limiting moscow's influence are the
objectives the question is how does nato
hope to achieve this why have these
three republics become a major focus of
interest for western institutions what
are their main strengths and weaknesses
and perhaps the most important question
of all could nato repel a
ukrainian-style russian invasion well in
this video we're going to answer these
and many other questions so let's get
started
[Music]
one country two societies
think about it for a moment what really
was the key factor that above all else
explains the success of the russian
intervention in ukraine okay i'm sure
many of you are thinking about the
troops russia put on the ground even if
they weren't bearing the flag and of how
those troops were prepared and equipped
however give it another twist would
russian success really have been
possible had it not been for the
existence of large pockets with russian
populations well you know what how would
you feel if i told you that this same
ingredient is also to be found here on
the border between the baltic republics
and mother russia look
[Music]
in lithuania today it is estimated that
4.8 of the country's population is
ethnic russian and yes this figure may
not seem particularly high to you but
lithuania is actually the exception
because the percentage of russian
population in estonia is around 24 and
in latvia even more 25.2 percent
[Music]
of course the fact that there is a
lesser or greater russian population in
a certain place is not necessarily a
negative thing the problem arises when
their social and legal situation has
come about due to their exclusion and
separation and that is precisely the
case
[Music]
look for example at the place that
you're going to see on screen laziness
this is a russian majority neighborhood
where only one in four inhabitants are
estonian here the russian community is
predominant we are talking about more
than 80 000 inhabitants who maintain
strong community ties with each other
and live in a real-life open-air museum
of the soviet era it's like russia but
inside estonia it is the main russian
nucleus within a city italian where more
than 30 percent of the population is
russia we are talking about a population
and this is the important thing that has
very marked characteristics of its own
[Music]
for example lowest income areas in the
three baltic republics are precisely
those where the highest percentage of
russians live and be careful because we
are not talking about a small variation
the income level can be 40 or even 50
lower than in the richest and most
prosperous areas
[Music]
but that's not all the russian
population in the baltic states
functions in practice as a kind of
second society or rather a second-rate
society and although their situation has
indeed improved over the last few years
the differences are still enormous
[Music]
for example in estonia to this day there
are still some 70 000 ethnically russian
people who are literally stateless yes
that's right some seventy thousand
people about six percent of the
country's entire population have no
citizenship no passport and no right to
vote in national elections and it is not
that they are russian citizens either we
are simply talking about 70 000 people
who are not citizens anywhere without
looking any further here in las nomine
we can find many examples of people who
formerly do not belong to any country
and yes i know what you're thinking how
on earth can this be possible
[Music]
well you see the origin of this bizarre
situation dates back to 1991 when the
estonian government made a firm decision
to grant citizenship exclusively to all
those who were citizens before the
soviet occupation in 1940 and their
descendants to the rest to the russians
who had arrived during the soviet
occupation nothing at all and take note
because something very similar happened
in latvia a country where about seven
percent of the population is in the same
situation we're talking about more than
130 000 stateless people well as you can
imagine this situation not only fuels
exclusion racial segregation and lack of
opportunities for this group of russian
population but it is also the perfect
breeding ground for the disinformation
and manipulation strategies sponsored by
the kremlin to be effective and you know
what in moscow they are perfectly aware
of that this is precisely why the
russian government has been trying for
years to fuel a sense of confrontation
and nation-building among this
population so how far have the russian
authorities gone and the most important
question of all what potential do such
strategies really have listen up
hybrid warfare
[Music]
where does it stem from why is russia so
interested in the baltic states is it a
question of mere historical resentment
is it perhaps to curb the influence of
the eu or is it a question of
neo-imperialism well the answer all of
those reasons and also none of them at
the same time on paper my friends
russia's argument is the idea of the
russian world now what exactly is this
russian world well you see vladimir
putin when he talks about russia and the
russian people he is not talking
exclusively about the russians living
within today's russian borders but about
all the russians scattered around the
world and especially in ex-soviet
territories it is so to speak an
expanded definition of the kremlin's
political responsibilities
[Music]
therefore the strategy of putin's
governments is to materialize this
concept of the russian world in this way
the government wants to link as many
russian-speaking minorities as possible
to the motherland why because they see
these russian minorities as a key
political tool for extending the
country's influence so much so that in
past wars moscow already alluded to the
idea of protecting its compatriots as
the main argument for intervening we are
talking for example about the war in
georgia or the military interventions in
crimea and the ukrainian don bass
now we are talking about the baltics and
the question we need to ask is what does
this all mean how does the russian
government intend to exert its influence
here well welcome to hybrid warfare
hybrid warfare is a type of
non-conventional conflict in which the
aim is to wear down the enemy by
combining political economic and
informational means for example methods
that are not strictly military in nature
this is achieved for example through
disinformation campaigns cyber attacks
blackmailing with energy supplies
interfering in electoral processes or
supporting and training radical and
insurgent groups all these tactics have
an enormous impact on a country's
security and also on the functionality
and even legitimacy of its institutions
[Music]
and yes almost all of these tactics are
what russia employs against the baltics
but do you want some concrete examples
then take a look
report russian hackers exploit
lithuanian infrastructure
suspected russia-backed hackers target
baltic energy networks and don't think
for a second that computer attacks are
the only examples on the table we can
find many many many more
without going any further it is known
that the russian government secretly
funded a group of news websites called
bolt news that were independent the
intention was to be able to disseminate
stories and news dictated directly by
the kremlin all with one purpose to turn
the baltics from a pro-western world
view to a more pro-russian one and to do
this they know that even more important
than influencing the political
establishment can be to do it in the
street to directly influence society
itself that is why it is so important to
carry out disinformation campaigns fake
news human rights denouncements data
capture and political and economic
threats but wait a minute because these
are not the only tools of hybrid warfare
that russia employs in this region of
europe either there is another even more
worrying one what we could call the
strategy of constant tension
the russian military presence in this
region is enormous we are talking about
such a concentration of equipment and
troops that many military experts doubt
that nato could really do anything to
stop a hypothetical russian invasion
something more than its supposed power
of deterrence of course but what exactly
is the russian military threat that
these three baltic countries estonia
latvia and lithuania may be facing well
let's take a closer look
[Music]
nato's achilles heel
this location that you're about to see
is the ploxtini missile base located in
western lithuania very close to the
baltic sea it was the first underground
nuclear strike base in the entire soviet
union this was one of the places the red
army counted on to deploy its
destructive power for years it was a hot
spot in the confrontation between east
and west today it reflects like few
others the triumph of the western bloc
once a key part of the soviet union's
own nuclear deterrence system today it
is a facility open to the public located
in a full member country of the north
atlantic treaty organization for decades
nato has been and remains a key tool a
counterweight in the world power system
democracy and freedom versus freedom
stifling autocracies this is true but it
is also true that this organization has
weaknesses delicate parts and some of
them can be found precisely in this
region of eastern europe
the three baltic states currently have
nato bases and troops deployed to defend
the borders separating the western bloc
from russia by land sea and air today
we're talking about more than 35 000
soldiers taking into account both the
national troops of these three countries
and the support units deployed by
countries such as the united states the
united kingdom germany and canada
of course in the hypothetical conflict
in the baltics russia not only wins in
numbers but also in means capabilities
and geo strategy let's look for example
at the case of lithuania this point you
are looking at is the subor key gap a
strip of about 90 kilometers that
connects lithuania with poland and the
rest of the nato countries in europe the
problem is that what surrounds this
corridor is hostile territory belarus to
the east and kaliningrad to the west
that is russia itself by the way not
long ago we made a video about cleaning
grab that helps to understand the
general context of the baltic cold war
which i'll leave you the link in the
description but let's not get
sidetracked
[Music]
the question is how easily russia could
isolate the three baltic states when the
time comes it would be enough to simply
occupy or attack this small strait of
land to prevent the transit of military
reinforcements it is so to speak a
funnel for nato forces and remember we
are not necessarily talking about an
occupation or a formal attack military
experts point to the mobilization of an
apparently irregular force similar to
those that russia used to occupy crimea
or to destabilize the donbass in fact
such an intervention is perhaps what the
three baltic countries are most
concerned about not only in this
corridor but above all in the parts of
their respective territories that have a
majority russian population but be
careful because this is not the only
weak point of nato in the vicinity of
kaliningrad the russian military has
deployed an advanced military system
that has created an a2ad anti-access
area denial capability
we are talking about a complex system
that makes it possible to prevent the
movement of adversarial forces by land
sea and air both in kaliningrad and in
neighboring areas this is achieved
thanks to a network of superimposed air
defense systems including since 2019 the
russian s 400 anti-aircraft system
long-range artillery conventional and
nuclear ballistic missiles including 12
dual use ice candar missiles and cruise
missiles there is also anti-ship and
anti-submarine weapons electronic
warfare systems and obviously numerous
military planes fighters and tanks among
many other pieces of equipment and let's
not forget the baltic fleet which is
stationed here to prevent nato from
using its fleets in the area against
russia in this way russia seeks not only
to perpetuate its dominion over
kaliningrad and protect its only baltic
port that does not freeze over all year
round but also to keep the three baltic
countries and thus nato as a whole at
bay
the problem with this kind of arm
wrestling and arms races is that a
simple mistake a misinterpretation or an
oversight at any given moment could set
things out of control that's the risk
latvia warns of risk of incident between
nato and russia
you have a border crisis you have a
major military exercise going on at the
borders of nato countries you also have
increased presence on our side the
lithuanian side the estonian side the
polish side of border guards and
military formations of course this is
increasing the possibility of incidents
edgar's rinkovics minister of foreign
affairs of latvia of course russia's
argument for maintaining a huge
deployment in the area is that from its
standpoint it is nato that has the
region surrounded for nato however
kaliningrad is a kind of russian
military fortress within the territory
of the bloc but look at this map on it
you can see the huge concentration of
military assets that russia has placed
on its western border for example in
pisgov just 20 miles from the estonian
border russia has an air assault
division and a russian special forces
brigade deployed putin's navy seals
[Music]
so without even counting on kaliningrad
forces many military experts suggest
that russia enjoys significant
operational superiority in the area nato
itself estimates that the russians would
be able to rapidly deploy between 50 000
and 60 000 soldiers in just a few days
in addition the threat to the baltic
countries could come from different
directions making defense of the area
even more difficult
but obviously today the possibility of
an armed conflict is reasonably small
and of course we cannot forget the
deterrent power that nato itself has but
what do you want me to say mistakes do
happen and we don't just have to think
about a chance incident the influential
presence of the russian community in
estonia and latvia it scanned
integration in civil and political life
and its relatively weak economic
situation could favor shock rebellion or
protest movements that could cause
significant damage to the stability of
the three baltic countries that is the
real threat and within it the game of
hybrid warfare and the constant tension
deployed by russia is the greatest asset
[Music]
but having got to this point it's your
turn do you think nato needs to increase
its deployment on its eastern border how
do you think western countries should
deal with a massive hybrid warfare
action in the baltics like the one that
has already occurred in ukraine in what
ways can the risks be contained leave us
your opinion below in the comments and
by the way if you like what we do now
you could be part of this project and
help it keep growing by joining our
community on patreon once again thank
you very much for being there all the
best and see you next time
[Music]